do you guys foresee a future of marriage
between the two of y'all
say no can't believe a marriage so no so
you don't believe in marriage because
you've never been married before right
no so it's just something you're just
not like I just don't see the point yeah
it doesn't make yeah I I respect it but
I'm getting married though you're
getting married to somebody
um
will it be hard to find somebody if your
ex's face is tattooed on your neck
I'm just I'm just curious because I feel
like once you've got the tattoo it
should be him right it should be
that wouldn't even make sense what
yeah I don't know I don't know
have for that I don't know right
with all the tattoos that's why I be
confused I'll be like